hello everybody and welcome to a formal
specification and taming other people's
tack my name is Marianne Bellotti I will
be your guide for today I had a really a
hard time figuring out what to name this
talk because really this is about
specifications for beginners by maybe
it's not fair to call myself a beginner
but certainly a non expert right but I
didn't really like calling it a for
beginners talk because it's so much more
interesting and compelling the kind of
powerful things you can do it's not just
about the basics of what you can do with
formal specifications it's about like
why you want to do this in the first
place and this is a really fun time to
kind of have come to this conference
which is one of my favorite conferences
to give a talk like this because it's
apparently like the unofficial theme of
strangelet this year formal
specification this is like one of three
different talks on the subject that you
can like watch and there was a pre call
on ela plus which is one of the larger
variants of formal specification so
let's start off with what exactly is
formal specification well if you think
about a written spec you this is
something that you might write down to
define roughly what it is you're
programming you might list your inputs
you might list your expected behaviors
look exactly what it is your program is
doing your legal outputs and then if
you're really clever or some illegal
behavior that you absolutely shouldn't
do with this program and the
significance of formal specification is
basically that we're putting this in a
structured syntax and then we're loading
it up into a model checker essentially a
computer that runs scenario analysis it
takes all of the possible states that it
can figure out from your spec and it
checks your illegal behavior and sees
four looks for states that have violated
your illegal behavior so this is super
cool you'll find some really interesting
bugs and other like things with your
code that you didn't expect to happen
but from personal experience like
learning this stuff feels like you're
riding in a speeding car going 60 miles
an hour straight into a brick wall like
the
in Kerrville and this is very very very
steep but I really like it because I
really like thinking in edge cases and
especially like outliers and things like
that so it was very from the moment that
I was introduced to it was very very
attractive to me as a concept I should
like full disclosure I should tell you
that um well I'm not a beginner I'm
probably pretty terrible at this stuff
but actually that was the main reason
why I wanted to give this talk rather
than like something I was scared of
because even though I think that most of
my sects are senseless and that they
don't add the level of value of some
other people that I've seen in this
community I still got a lot of value out
of it and we still found bugs in our
code and we've it's still like increased
the rigor of my engineering practice and
this sort of tied more broadly into my
philosophical perspective on engineering
teams themselves right now I'm an
engineering manager I run engineering
teams and one of the things I tell the
engineers that work for me is that you
will never understand something on the
level that you need to understand it
when you have to teach it to somebody
else so the least efficient engineering
teams in my experience the ones that are
filled with experts and geniuses and the
most efficient ones are the ones that
have a more diverse array of like
experts and people who are just starting
to figure out like all the things that
they need to know in order to make this
work and so one of the conversations
we've been having is we've just been
overloaded and spoiled with all of this
content about formal specifications this
weekend is like how do we get more
people involved in this community
why if these tools are so powerful are
they not broader used and I think it's
really because we have such like this
glut of experts and that when you come
into the community you get hit with the
barrier to entry and the next thing you
notice is they're all these like super
amazing legendary programmers who are
using it and you are not one of them and
that's very intimidating so the point of
this talk is primarily to like lower the
intimidation factor and kind of
introduce different ways you can start
to use formal specifications that are
not
commonly part of the conversation
because what is generally part of the
conversation is the AWS use case of like
oh they use it to build s3 isn't that
cool it is very cool and like Oh
Microsoft uses it for Emma's I for as
your services isn't that cool and this
is also very cool but the reality of it
is that most software engineers will
never build their own message queue
right you'll download something it's
open source you'll buy it from your
cloud provider you're not going to start
to like just build your own message
queues for for fun and yet you can use
specification for lots of other things
so I give you a little bit of background
I work for auth0
we do identity as a service basically
what that means is logins and
specifically I run the platform services
teams which are shared services that all
the other engineering teams of all Xero
use and so these include things like
rate limits future flies email
notifications so on and so forth and
what's significant to know about my team
is that by and large we did not build
the services that we now own what
usually happens is an engineering team
at all zero needs a particular service
and they get really excited and they go
and they build the this service that
they need and then other engineering
teams see it and they go that's really
cool I also need that service can i hook
in and use your service and they go sure
and so this goes on and we get broader
and broader adoption until finally the
original engineering team goes you know
actually we have a product roadmap and
like literally none of this stuff is on
the product roadmap so we can't really
maintain this service that now everyone
is using so this is where my team kind
of comes in we come in and we take over
the service and sometimes they've been
working beautifully but they haven't
actually been maintained there may have
things that are out of date with them
there may be problems that are not
although not significant or pretty
structural and so we come in and if
there are no SLO as we define us all
those we evaluate the situation of
technical debt and then we study the
existing problems and kind of look at
rethinking the architecture so there's
one service I'm going to talk about a
lot in this session
and it's our email notification service
and so we're not an email company we
don't want to run your mail server for
you right like we do logins we don't do
emails but if you think about the
workflow of login it's still very
heavily dependent on email email is like
the lowest level of identity proofing
right so we have an issue because like
what we would really like you to do is
go to some of these companies like
SendGrid mandrill spark post and like
sign up for an account with them even a
free account because like they run mail
servers their mail providers that's what
they do and so they can put all the time
and resources into doing that super well
we want you to do that and then
integrate those services with us but we
also want to make our onboarding
experience as smooth and effortless as
possible so if you're signing up for an
account with us and I need to say like
ok stop now go to this completely other
company and sign up for an account there
and then come back we lose a whole bunch
of people right away right so what do we
do we have this thing called the shared
provider which is basically like a
little mail server that we maintain so
when you're onboarding you're getting
used to using the product you're
figuring it out you can have emails and
everything works great and the
compromise that we make here is that we
keep saying like please don't use this
in production we also rate limit you you
get a certain number of emails per hour
that you can send for the shared
provider under the old algorithm when
you exceeded that rate limit what we did
with the emails that came through after
that is we dumped them into a retry
queue and waited a little bit until your
rate limit had gone back up and then
retried them but designing this service
to work this way assumes that email is
kind of grow in a fairly linear fashion
when you first sign up you have a low
level of email traffic and then as it
goes you get higher and higher and so
eventually you get to the point where
you're going over that rate limit fairly
predictably and then we get to call you
up and say hey by the way did you hear
we're not an email company but there are
some great great companies that we can
refer you to that will like fix this
problem for you please don't use the
shared provider for production anymore
um but that's not actually the behavior
that we see on the
provider the behavior that we actually
see looks more like this there'll be a
fairly low level of email traffic and
then the user will do something I gotta
be honest
usually by accident that blasts out an
email to literally all of their users
all at once now sometimes that's like a
couple hundred emails sometimes that's
like a couple hundred thousand emails so
what would happen is that the retrack
you would fill up to the point where it
would take many many hours for it to
send all those emails and pager duty
would go off and one of my engineers
would get woken up in the middle of the
night to essentially log on and run a
command that would basically just clear
all of these emails out of the retry
queue so when they were taking me for
this for the first time they were like
what we want to do is we want to change
the rate-limiting algorithm so that
instead of retrying it we just delete
them because we're going to delete them
anyway so why don't we just automate it
right but there's this question how do
we know that that behavior is safe
because once you delete something you're
kind of yeah that's it right like
there's no real undo dropping an email
so this is the point where I was like
cool I'm gonna write some specs up be
right back
right and this is where we're gonna get
into the nitty-gritty of like how should
you think about like formal
specification and the first piece of
advice I want to give you is that when
you if you're a programmer you're used
to thinking of algorithms as being in
steps and when you start specifying
things you need to start thinking about
them as being in States because what
model checkers do is they look for every
possible combination of state that can
be valid in your spec and if your spec
has branching logic in it then they look
for every possible combination of those
branches and so on and so forth so
depending on how much variance you have
programmed in due respect this can be a
lot and lot a lot a lot lot of
situations and model checkers are
usually able to handle this pretty
efficiently because some of these
branches some of these states may
violate some conditions that you've
written in in which case the model
checker will just error automatically
and say by the way I found an error and
some of them it's smart enough to go oh
I've seen this series of states before
I've already checked
that it's fine just forget it whatever
but the concepts of states is pretty as
significant to formal specification for
one reason or another a couple months
ago I decided that I really wanted to
start playing around with using formal
specification to model interactions
between systems and I started with load
balancers this idea of you have a
cluster of machines and a load balancer
and like how did the configuration of
that load balancer affect the safety of
that cluster and I was like when I first
wrote the the first spec I wrote was
actually like super literal on that
point right so I was like we've got
three vm's we are using CPU utilization
as the sign of whether they're healthy
or unhealthy and so like they can have
anywhere from zero to 100 CPU
utilization and seventy means they're
unhealthy and bla bla bla bla and I want
to test all the possible states and
combinations to see like whether the
world balancer does the right thing fine
except if you are running all of these
scenarios you end up with a lot of
scenarios that kind of don't like
they're not worthwhile to test right so
if we know that something is good at 45%
CPU utilization and we know it's good at
47 percent utilization testing 46%
utilization is kind of a waste of CPU
cycles on my Shivam machine and
certainly a whole bunch of time so I was
like cool I know what I'm gonna do here
I'm gonna divide it by 10 so that it's
we're only testing between 0 and 10
instead of 0 and 100 and that will do it
and that was much better than I was
testing like 40% of 50% 60% but it still
wasn't super satisfying I didn't feel
like I was really testing anything
important and then I realized that
really the only thing that mattered was
whether it was healthy or unhealthy and
the numbers I had assigned to that
healthy or unhealthy were completely
irrelevant I didn't need to bother with
the numbers all what I needed to do was
design a state machine essentially and
so I went back and I rethought about
this and I was like ok so we have our
cluster and it has three states it's
either in an or
State easy they're not enough work for
all the machines so it's idle or too
much work for all the machines it's
unhealthy and it sort of toggles between
these three states and that's very easy
to build super super simple smack around
I can just basically say these are my
three states and this is the branching
logic that leads from one to the other
and then I can set some constraints on
it that says like hey there should be
like more than 0 of servers and like
let's say 11 servers is over provisioned
and an AWS like knocks me out at that
point so let's say it should be less
than 10 servers right so there's a
problem with this model that makes it
frustrating and and and feel like it's
not useful useful endeavor and that is
it kind of factors in a lot of
probability and you wanna when you're
doing specs kind of leave your notion of
probability at home just divorce
yourself from it everything is all equal
regardless of how like you're unlikely
it is and the reason why this is a
problem for this spec is because when
you run it you'll have like these
thousands of scenarios where sometimes
the load balancer kills the server and
sometimes the load balancer creates a
server and like it mainly stays
somewhere in the bounds of that between
0 and 10 and then you will have the one
case where it literally just keeps
killing the server over and over and
over and you will run this model and the
first thing you will say is like I found
a problem you could just keep killing
the server forever and I'm like yeah no
dahhh but that feels like it would never
happen in real life or that would happen
very rarely and that's not the kind of
bugs that are going to impress people on
Hacker News so this is really just not
it's not whatever - right so like you
really gonna remember the the the formal
specifications is designed for system
safety it's designed for the idea of
correctness it's not designed for thumbs
up looks good no problem don't worry
about it so any any state that could
violate conditions is considered equal
to all of the other states in in that
full array it doesn't matter that there
are a million states where everything is
fine if there's one
stay where things are not fine that it
that is considered just as important as
the millions of cases where everything
is fine but this state machine is
actually also a bit naive
truth be told because a load balancers
don't arbitrarily flip a coin and decide
you're healthy and you're not healthy
there's another state that's not
represented in it which is the health
check so I was like all right let's go
back and smaadahl the health check and
so and by the way this is like the the
most complicated spec you're gonna see
in this talk so like if you can handle
this you're good the Ida this is just a
quick model of a health check and there
are a couple things you need to know
about it essentially what it says is it
specifies that if there are several
unhealthy servers then you create a new
server if all the servers are healthy
but there are more than three then you
shut one down and else we're gonna just
assume that if there are a couple and
healthy servers but not enough to do
anything about we're gonna just kill
them and reboot them and go back to the
way things were in the beginning and
this was also very unsatisfying for very
particular reason and that is this line
of code right here um Here I am
incrementing a variable called cycle by
one and the reason why I was doing this
is because I thought oh but wait I've
definitely seen cases where the little
balancers just keep rebooting servers
over and over and over and over and over
again how would I represent that oh well
I would increment it every time it
cycles and then that would tell me when
that was happening and this was about
the point when I realized this
fundamental flaw and how is approaching
this issue is that I wasn't actually
divining a difference between a state
being impossible and a state being
simply undesirable and I was gravitating
towards all of these states that were
undesirable but like totally normal
things that we know load balancers do we
know load balancers occasionally just
kill servers over and over and over
again that doesn't make them unsafe that
just means that like priorities we don't
define this as an impossible condition
so I started to realize
I really need to start thinking about
what states are impossible rather than
what states are simply like nasty to
deal with right so this is kind of like
one of the things that I really love
about formal specifications is that I
keep finding myself in places where it
completely flips my thinking about
programming concepts and about how I'm
approaching problems and I find that
really engaging maybe a little bit of a
masochist on that point so now we got to
start asking ourselves which state
should be impossible given what we're
thinking about in terms of our state
machine and not simply just undesirable
so let's go back to my shared provider
our mail server I need to like back up a
little bit and explain a little bit
about how our rate limiting algorithm
works we use something called a token
bucket algorithm actually technically we
use a leaky token bucket bucket
algorithm but the leaky for the purpose
of this talk is not pretty significant
so I'm just gonna like simplify it a
little bit on this front and the way
token bucket algorithm works is that you
have a bucket per customer and that
bucket can fit a certain number of
tokens that get issued at a certain
constant rate and when an email comes in
and says I would like to be sent out to
the world it goes through the bucket and
the bucket says here's your token go on
by right and when the email comes in and
there are no tokens the token bucket
says sorry you got to go off to the
retry queue for you
wait around until there are more tokens
in the bucket and so to be clear we
don't actually write code to represent
buckets and tokens this is done in Redis
and it's done mainly with timestamps and
pre-designed constants about like rates
of tokens into the bucket and how many
tokens could fit in a bucket and whatnot
so given all of this though how do we
make this look like a state machine
well our email has three basically three
states we go from queued to a worker to
sent and then our token bucket has two
states it is either either has tokens or
it has no tokens
and so it from a state machines
perspective that looks basically like
this with a good email going from queer
to create queued to with the worker to
check the token to either send or
retried back to the queue and we want to
change it to this queued with the worker
sent or dropped and given this what
states with the state machine should be
impossible well if we have a token we
shouldn't just be deleting emails uh if
there's no token it shouldn't be sent if
it's deleted it shouldn't be been sent
and if it's sent it shouldn't be deleted
although in fairness that last one maybe
not such a big deal in the first place
but anyway these are the states that
should be illegal given this state
machine and so how does our
implementation prevent these states and
this is the point where I kind of say
the thing that I most appreciate about
formal specifications is that a lot of
times I don't have to actually run the
model I've already found something out
that's really useful insignificant just
by trying to think through how the hell
I'm gonna write the specification in the
first place and this is definitely a
situation where we had a couple of those
trying to write this model we go back to
this idea of we got these huge bulk
blasts of emails and we want to just
delete them automatically but then we
think to ourselves wait a minute
what if when we get this huge blast of
say like email validation emails there's
a user on this Tennant's website or
application or whatever they're using us
for who is trying to login and has
forgotten their password that would mean
that the bucket is stripped of all its
tokens we're now deleting emails and oh
shoot we just deleted an email that
really should have gone out in the first
place and so like what do we do about
this how do we solve this and what we
realized is oh wait a minute we don't
need we need multiple buckets for all
the email types so that you can blow
away your tokens for one type and the
emails from the other type still go
through because they're still allowed to
it's like okay great so what should that
look like right and so we start to think
about this in terms of like well we've
got certain amount of tenants those are
our customers and then we've got certain
number email types that we rate limit
and so like that's X number buckets and
so like maybe we're building like a spec
based on like for each tenet there are a
certain number of buckets and what does
that look like so this is the part where
like I talked about the thing that drove
me the most crazy for the longest period
of time and that is loops loops and
specs right loops will mess you up right
largely because there are some formal
specification types that don't have them
at all
and then there are some formal
specification types that have what looks
like a loop from a programmers
perspective but behaves very differently
so for example let's suppose that we had
a list of possible states a B and C we
iterate through it and we print out the
current state if we ran this spec what
the spec would print out would be a and
then B and then C exactly what we'd
expect now let's change it a little bit
let's say we have a list another list
outside of the loop and then we take
that same situation but instead of
printing out the current state we append
it to the list that's outside of the
loop and then we print that what is what
do we think this one prints something
like this maybe yeah okay no it doesn't
at all if you wrote this this is what it
prints it for it's a list with a in it
it prints a list in B with it and it
prints a list with C in it and has drove
me absolutely crazy because I was doing
much more complicated things than than
this and it was just not working out and
I didn't understand why but the reason
why it does this is again we go back to
that concept of steps versus States when
you iterate something in a programming
language you're going a then B then C
when you iterate something in a spec you
are probably creating a branch of all of
those states so instead you're going a
or B or C and the fact that it does this
in roughly the same order
is where it appears in the list is kind
of just irrelevant it's just the way it
does it right so given that we realize
that we don't need to model a whole
bunch of tenants and then a whole bunch
of buckets we really need to do is focus
on this very simple relationship between
a tenant with a certain number of
buckets per email type and actually we
really just need to focus on email types
going to the correct buckets and then
once we got it down to that then it was
like oh wait this is basically the kind
of problem that you see in like every
like intro to formal specification like
Alice wants to send Bob some money for
her account and does she have money in
her account like it's basically the same
sort of problem we're trying to figure
out if the the message is going to the
correct bucket and if we have capacity
in that bucket so it was like okay cool
we can do it that way but let's go back
to this idea of undesirable versus
impossible because there's another
problem that we found while writing this
back which is okay we go back to this we
got a bulk blast of email over
verification emails out of tokens start
dropping emails and then at the same
time instead of a password reset we get
a user that tries to create a new
account on this particular application
and what do we do when we create a new
account we send an e-mail verification
email so now we have another state where
a single email that is not related to
the bulk email problem that we are
trying to solve is getting caught up and
deleted when it probably shouldn't be
but there's a question of like whether
this is a state that should be
impossible or whether it's simply
undesirable and something that we can
say to the customer you should not be
using this for a live application in
production please again go to any one of
these beautiful companies that will be
more than happy to do all your emails
right but what's really significant
about this issue is that we can't
actually solve it with our rate-limiting
right it's really difficult to solve
that kind of issue with our rate
limiting what we need to do in order to
solve it is go further up the pipeline
to the publishers and these are all zero
engineering
teams that are building different parts
of our service that are basically
jumping emails into work queue and so we
spent some time with that like how do
you solve for a problem like that and
then that just kind of triggered the
question of like wait why are we letting
publishers just dump things straight
into our queue because actually when we
spend some time to think about it there
are a whole bunch of problems that if we
simply put up an HTTP endpoint that they
would use to put emails into the queue
would also be solved by doing that we
could get better tracking of like bulk
actions and prevent them but we could
also do better in valve verification of
data and if we wanted to migrate off our
current message queue and on to
something different we could do that
more easily that if we were letting them
just dump it right into the queue so to
summarize these are my basic thoughts on
how you should start to approach formal
specifications that you do not have to
have the the the terrible hop field
climb that I had this process first one
is make it look like a state machine
second one is define the states that
should be impossible given that state
machine third piece of advice then focus
your model on what makes that impossible
what prevents that state from happening
and so if you want some help about
getting started some inspiration I got
some ideas because it turns out there
are lots of things that you probably use
on your engineering team right now that
already look like state machines so for
example yesterday table plus pre-con
folks talking to somebody and he's like
I really want to use telia press but I
don't know like where to even start and
I'm a front-end engineer and it was
awesome do you use react and he was like
yeah I was like do use Redux and I'm
just like yeah I was like Redux
is the state machine so you're halfway
there already and actually this is a
common enough like realization that
there are a couple blog posts about like
Redux as a state machine and using model
checking
when I was at there
personally two years ago a shout-out to
a curse center there was somebody
actually working on modeling their Redux
application with TL A+ as if it was a
state machine and so like that there's a
fair for TI plus there's a fair amount
of documentation on how you want to
approach that other thing that looks
like a state machine AWS lamda has this
thing called step functions that will
basically turn lambdas into state
machines so that's another opportunity
if you're using that you can sort of
start from there and start modeling
things and then if you're doing any kind
of work full orchestration there's
technically a difference between
workflow orchestration and state
machines but for the purposes of this
kind of modeling it's kind of irrelevant
what the difference between them is so
if you're using air flow or conductor or
Luigi or anything like that you already
have something that looks like a state
machine ready to go in your stack and
you can sort of start to go from there
so that basically brings me to the end
of my talk if this is of any interest to
you you can reach out to be over the
slack and I will also say that I am
hiring for my team and especially what
we're looking for are young hungry
software engineers that we can grow and
invest in so you're sitting here
thinking that sounds cool but way too
advanced for me no no come come and show
me what you got basically alright thank
you guys I'll be around after the talk
you want to chat
[Applause]